okay for people who are joining this
livestream something a little different
today
we are about to launch our function
repository and I wanted to take a look
through some of the contributed
functions in the function repository and
try and understand more about the style
guidelines that we want to use um and
make some last-minute fixes and it
should all be super easy that's the
theory at least
okay so we've just picked random
functions from the function repository
let's launch here arcsine degree
well looks fine I mean I think that some
of these will just say it's fine I mean
there's nothing to say about this one
I'm good with this one too full string
greatest string of the full form of
expression with fully qualified system
name symbol names I mean by the way the
best thing here is if I can just grind
through them and I just the yeah
obviously this fuzziness here in the
output is wrong and but you guys are
working on that right yeah I'm so
looking at that is that one missing
details and options or does it not have
any I think I just didn't put anything
down okay
all right just this may be a very boring
meeting if every one of these is just a
okay create the directory for a good
file if it does not already exist that
is a very weird name
we've had insured directory in general
utilities for a while that people sort
of know about that creates the directory
that you specify this one goes up one in
the file path the parent directory of
whatever you specify just a really weird
name I mean insurer is some I mean it
wouldn't wouldn't it be insured file
path
yeah that might I think either one
because we have to come over right
suburb like create it could be create
but it might already exist
we don't you like create directory and
you know throws an error if you already
have the directory so this ignores it so
that's why it's I think it should be in
sugar verb I think it should be insured
and that's not a change it's easy for me
to make would you guys be able to make
that yeah should it also this just
occurred to me and insured parent
directory and not file path because
that's essentially what it does what
does it do they just make sure that the
file paths that you give it and make
sure that the parent directory exists so
they could be doing a put or something
it's not gonna create intermediate
directories for you system tells the
full what well okay why don't you Rick
why don't you make whatever change you
think you should make to this since it's
your function okay yeah
hmm this claims to be mine
the first example is a little well
doesn't have a lot of choice
unfortunately all I agree it's way too
complicated
um Brian on the live stream is asking
about the previous one does it does it
walk the path all the way to the top to
ensure all the directories exist Rick
yeah it does I was just answering in the
chat actually okay so why isn't it I
mean insured file path seems like a good
name creates the parent directory of
path I kind of like it sure just because
it's like great actually
no you're right it is the right thing
I'm sorry it this is right this is fine
hi do you think parent directory makes
more sense than file path though hmm I
don't know it's taking the file path it
returns since it returns the same file
distance or transpile death and not
returning the parent directory now I
think it's the right thing I think it's
the right thing I think that the look I
think it would be this is a bad
description here I mean it should say
something like create the sequence of
directories create the parent
directories necessary to fill out a file
part to fill out the path for the
specified file path that make sense
yeah and it should say parent
directories plural in the function
research some who sang on the livestream
veteran show Papa that leads to one item
list that contains yeah right that's the
issue of should have direct hit from yes
it should direct hit just like the main
thing does if it's a total match
probably not if it's just a single
result but if it's a complete match you
know exactly it's same rules as for the
standard documentation yes
okay Huffman decode needs a simpler
example but I'm afraid Huffman decode
depends on Huffman encode what is
Huffman code words oh my gosh by the way
this doesn't have separator lines
because those didn't exist in the
documentation stuff shall I go fix this
one let me go fix this one okay so what
do I do now to go fix this okay and now
why don't I go ahead and save this in
some appropriate place I'm gonna save
this let me go ahead and save it in
general box repositories function
repository that's
it um
functional reviews what's that how does
it say live review but that works a
function review function reviews plural
okay so here I would want to let's get
out my tools thing here insert delimiter
you
you
CACO totes Wikipedia article okay it's
hardly the most impressive they done
function here
now the other one that you were pointing
out was the Huffman decode one which had
a horrific ly complicated um example
there
and let me see what I can do with this
so
you know I mean why don't we just kill
so do have a husband looks like there's
failure with this one here so Huffman
what where is the seal so and source
initial information there's related
resource objects this
why are those new you IDs those are
that's crazy it's probably when we
standardize probably okay so those there
should be they should be no that should
be Huffman encode and probably Huffman
code word to accept we have no idea what
that one is
okay so can we can we make a positive
check for that in other places yeah and
we need to understand that's what I'm
saying is that well I don't know whether
they should or shouldn't butt in the
back end there start that way but they
need to be turned into names renders a
notebook okay
um arguably let's see that this should
be something yeah we're not going fast
enough we probably should go faster
because these these things are not
changing the examples is desirable but
not you know essential so to speak that
might be a better example
up the snow I didn't um so for this I
evaluate this right and then I just say
redundancy yeah that's nice
now do I do is it come on seven here
decoe yes and you know I could start
just typing in all kinds of funky things
anybody know how to get the two more
sequence out
that's a substitution system see this is
where I get into trouble because I'm
about to start doing something that I
shouldn't be doing right it's more
productive I think there are several
ways in which Stephen nothing you want
to hear this but that you're going in
the wrong direction here because we can
focus on rewriting those functions that
we ourselves contributed but there's
going to be a focus on outside
contributions and I don't know that
we're always going to want to do a heavy
rewrite when it comes to those no but I
think it is worth our while to give
feedback on those I think that's one of
the important things
no no objection there but I don't want
to give people the idea that we're just
gonna completely overhaul what they sent
you know without without going to them
that cetera et cetera yeah I agree I
agree
um let's use something like this um I
think also as Bob said I think was Bob
we really want to get into some breaths
here more than depth okay I'm just I'm
goofing off here sort of but um okay
because okay just one second here we
might as well just do this since I'm
already in it um um whoever's making
background noise could you put yourself
on mute please
that's exceptionally boring that one is
just like not even worth having um how
do I do one which isn't totally trivial
okay look I'm gonna leave it Rick
other or somebody just just fill in
something that isn't totally trivial
here okay
oh you know what I just need a third
symbol that's the way to do it
you
you
you
you could do like let's
stomer let's not spend animal ours okay
inversion vector q
checks if IV is the aversion back
a mutation list it's a semi technical
thing because we also have now inversion
vector to inversion Barratt or something
like that okay all right those notes the
Tod
they're very hard yeah I mean that's
something we probably shouldn't allow we
should only we should say everything has
to be you know we should just say that's
that everything really should just be
one line here and that's part of the the
checking and then you know it should
build itself up in the right way yeah I
really shouldn't be like that
I mean is that the worst crime in the
world no but that's part of the checking
should disallow that cloud put by hash
okay well that's a good idea we were
talking about
- something just recently yeah it's a
really good idea okay pebble stone
effect okay great
magnificent
why does it I don't understand if
there's some way of changing this
parameter why is that not part of the
why on earth is that not part of the
original function here this thing this
wacky thing whatever it is again we
might as well just record these comments
so we can feed them back to the authors
let's try it I mean these are Semyon
took these are internal authors but
let's feed back that comment see what
happens see what I'm saying yep I mean
we might as well have a second argument
which is that thing the scaling of the
curves if that's what's relevant a
synchronous dynamic module that sounds
scary a wrapper for dynamic modules
which cause the place all to be shown
during the slow station wowie what an
earth is this
and this week as he sets up the actual
use of the function its what for him
with it wasn't this is like this is a
property relation example it's the first
one right this this example is
contrasting this with the standard
dynamic module yeah I understand yeah
yeah it's very weird but I mean I think
it's that's probably not the right way
to do it but again it's not heinous this
is this is definitely a usable thing
you
it's kind of cool I mean again you know
let me make another comment this is
something that we should obviously
consider for as something for dynamic
module itself as an option or even
possibly default behavior why isn't that
default behavior of a dynamic module
that's the first one of these where I
think that it's a potential built-in
thing yeah okay so let's communicate
that to the front end group and ask them
whether that's something that they would
like to build in okay Karl is asking on
the live stream he says it's got
something to convert epsg codes whatever
those are to geo projections but it's
multiple functions it's okay to be a few
functions but I mean how many functions
you know if it's a couple of functions
it's okay and something like hundred
lines of data not a problem and by the
way we're adding something that allows
you to specify initialization once and
for all for certain functions and you
can also use the once function to set up
initialization but yeah just because it
isn't small doesn't mean it doesn't fit
I mean if it's 18 functions then start
worrying but hopefully it doesn't have
to be 18 functions select first by
you
that's kind of cool except I'd why is
that order incorrect the buy functions
have their have their criterion lost
right and this isn't to select I think
well this one is the wrong way round
and there's some mapping or something
going on right yeah this is this is a
crazy function this is one of the
general utilities ones sorry yeah but
just because it's been in general
utilities doesn't mean that we put it in
without thinking about it I mean this is
a good piece of functionality
I see
I mean the natural way
would be to have these arguments in the
exact opposite order
I think wouldn't it I mean if it's sort
well yes no I think the buys comes last
that factorial is third but but the
range ten should come first
yes it sort of seems like a combination
of map and select all right right yes
yeah I'd I don't so like factorial then
the range then the condition kind of
seems like it makes sense to me I'm
sorry what do you say so to make it
similar to map like the factorial would
be the first argument than the list
you're mapping it across and then the
condition would be third but typically
our by functions the system context by
functions do not have to buy first in
his second or third I believe right but
maybe this is really map select first
it's arguably I mean this is probably
the wrong name all right we're gonna
select first until it's not until it's
only giving the first one it's always
giving the first one it is will select
first by in the sense that other things
are you know of other by functions up to
the fact that the argument ordering is
different okay well what would it be if
it was if it was argument ordered by
select first by would have the by
criterion lost I believe that's true and
that that list that it selects from
would be first yeah so in this case it
would be range of 10 and then well let's
here let's get this pure function the
selection function and then we do by
function this this limit the pie so
you're saying it would be range of 10
then hash greater than 1000 and then
what it's by correct because this would
be a pure select yeah you're right this
is the right way around yeah this is
wrong okay if you wanted to be
consistent with take largest but it
isn't the same as it take so take
largest doesn't have that pure function
possibility it just has an N by the way
Steve on the live stream is asking what
if all these functions are in github
repos we have absolutely thought about
this and we've decided not to do this
the because it's not as useful to have
many Forks of these things as it is to
have a canonical form I'm in the process
of writing a grand blog post which I
actually have just started revising
because I realized that I hadn't quite
understood the right point could you put
yourself on mute please I was making
that much they've um and our scheme is
you can say send a message about this
function and you can send that message
and it will go back to the the author of
the function and they are then
responsible for updating it and there's
a procedure if they don't successfully
update it and we'd love to have a
community involved in essentially
reviewing these things and and
generating updates but we don't think I
mean by the way anybody can deploy their
own version of one of these functions it
just won't be the canonical version
until it's gone back through this review
process so you can you can deploy this
thing to the public in your account to
the public cloud and you can give
anybody the the the link to that to your
version of this function but we want the
canonical version of the function
initially would be owned by the original
creator of the function unless they
flake out basically um we'd love to have
comments on this and and I think you
know we're really really hoping that the
community will help push all this
forward okay you know what can that's a
horrendous piece of code there okay I'm
gonna leave it to somebody else to fix
this okay I'm not gonna fix this one
consult there's also just I want to
mention here that this should probably
return seven not fifty forty should
return something in the range of ten if
it's like a site like optimization thing
you know yeah no I I understand all that
but but it should still it shouldn't
return fifty forty yeah cuz that's not
in the original list you're selecting
from in light that's true you're right
it's kind of like supposed to be
equivalent to mapping factorial across
that whole range and then taking the
first one that's a condition but it'll
function as a mess this function is a
mess it should be some kind of map
whatever thing let's not let's not solve
this right now you guys think about this
this function is not great um uh okay
comments an other comments from
livestream here
d8 is commenting all the functions are a
CC BY wish it were MIT license what is
the distinction that we should care
about there because that's pretty
arbitrary what we're doing there um you
know we thought that was the most the
thing that would make the most sense
um versioning information yeah it's a
complicated thing the versioning
information is you we actually have
internal versioning information there's
the question of when if you have code
that depends on one of these functions
does it get blowing up if there's a new
version complicated story more to say
about that you'll see on the on your
screen right now there's a resource
history field on the shingle so there's
at least some window into when things
were up to so sorry what on your screen
right now there's a resource history if
this when we modify this an updated
it'll say I don't have an updated date
there so you'll know when things have
changed from the web page and like you
said there are versions available we
just need to write so Simon is
commenting that open source projects
often don't suffer from lots of forks
I understand I mean the goal here is to
make sure that if people have written
code that relies on one of these
functions that it doesn't just get blown
up from underneath them that's the
that's the issue and that's you know
that is a common problem and I think
that the right answer here is if you
want to fork it then you can absolutely
fork it and you have a version that you
serve out of your own cloud account um
and people can use that and then you
know the exact processes by which it
becomes the canonical version we don't
fully understand and hopefully the
community can help define those
processes um they uh yeah when some of
the updates the function should have
historical tracking yes we we know and
there's there's a bunch of issues about
making sure that api's continue to work
and so on and we have a whole mechanism
because sometimes we have customers for
example who want to set up an API and
they wanted to work forever and we have
to deal with um being able to sort of
guarantee that that will happen or have
some mechanism for fixing that Oh
somebody's saying I can't wait to
surprise function so that I can call
them a mess sorry I just I speak my mind
it's it's it's my I'm um uh okay so um
sander wants one reviewed why not let's
look at it um
okay
you
towards a random point inside the
reference geometry reg by jumping
halfway and this is Sanders I I just I
speak my mind here the UM uh yeah so to
d8 by those saying you can focus put in
your own github repo absolutely the only
thing that that isn't going to work
there and which is an interesting issue
that we've been talking about is the see
what's really cool here is that if I
take this and I copy paste it it will
just work he says right and I don't have
to do any downloading connecting URLs
anything it's just going to work and the
you know the trade-off is to have that
just work there has to be sort of a
canonical version and so on so if it's
in somebody's repo then you've got to
give some URL to that repo and you know
I I could replace this with a URL um
let's see could I replace that with a
URL to a github repo yes I mean we could
make that work but right now it has to
be a cloud object URL that's something
we can definitely add support for though
seems sensible to me I mean why not if
it's an arbitrary URL of course then we
very carefully specify what can be there
ya know then it gets into all kinds of
cans of worms because you know this is a
very seamless process and so if somebody
has code there that says you know you
know delete the file system or something
you're just kind of loaded in you're
gonna run it and it's going to delete
your filesystem and that's very very bad
and we've obviously guaranteed that the
functions that are in the function
repository don't do things like that um
so that's that's you know that's the
trade-off here is and I think that the
you know curation sort of review thing
I'm you know and again we really want to
work with the community and figure out
the best way to have people involved in
this and to have
people be admins for example there's
there's no reason that can't be
community members who are admins on the
function repository um that you know by
no means all has to be us in fact we'd
be delighted if it wasn't all us um we
just have to figure out how that's all
gonna work okay let me try to understand
this chaos game thing this is obviously
kind of complicated so if I were to give
let's see region Y is the three-year
region so if I say like Pentagon here um
that's not going to work is it if I say
um regular polygon five is that sensible
or is that gonna do something oh cool no
what the heck it did but it did
something cool um reference geometry
this function is somewhat complicated as
my okay create the classic thing okay
jump only 40 percent of the way towards
these reference points okay so that's
the number of points that's the that's
the polygon count presumably so
presumably if I were to say seven here
um
okay it's an interesting question why
the sierpinski thing worked so much
better than the other ones don't
understand that jump between four
corners of trapezoid okay so at least
I'm understanding what the initial point
is there um
okay I mean this is a good example of a
somewhat specialized function
generating graphics which i think is
probably reasonable um this doesn't look
bad at all
I mean this is somewhat complicated and
I don't think we can
whole thing but it's looks format okay
so that's okay whether it returns
graphics or lists this looks like a good
example of a fairly specialized thing
our mission choices why is there an
option called choices it's that I see so
so that is similar Wow okay I predict
that if one really ground the stone one
could turn it into this really doesn't
look bad but there might be some simple
way to do things like that thinking
about hmm um
oh that's addressed and kale skin was
already in use so this was generalized
cow skin now that's a little bit of an
upset of course because that's another
issue here is the namespace um happens
is this compatible with isolate an end
gone that n is the wrong font to their
okay is this is the design at all
compatible between these and that's
again an issue of course um hey
whoever's new muted muted please
what does iterator is the number of
iterations
it's a little unfortunate the
first example isn't a default and I see
what on earth
and this one generates a listers output
whereas the other one generates I mean
honestly the fact that the other one
generates a graphic as output might be
an excuse to give a name like um yeah
okay so this was look this is a
collision of names and this is this is
definitely a bit frustrating um
comments about this I mean this is what
can happen you know somebody can grab a
name um and this by the way undoubtedly
doesn't refer to generalized cows game
and should and how does that come to
happen suggesting and as people add
things they really do need to suggest
where the thing could be linked from in
other words where do they want to market
their thing from um
so this is a slightly different design
well that's what's gonna happen here I
mean that's the difference between this
being a built-in function I mean both of
these are perfectly usable and perfectly
you know they're things to do based on
the documentation let's keep going
without with our effort to review things
okay
so ensure directory I'm kind of guessing
is the same deal okay
I think the documentation could be
better but it's not terrible there okay
let's go ahead and just in the sake of
getting through lots of things here
let's go start looking at some others
sell information oh that's interesting a
sign and generate a notebook object okay
but so if I would go back here and I
would say notebooks um and for example I
was to get the select first notebook so
I could say could I not could I say um
this is really kind of horrific this is
a horrific non example of the examples
there so what happens is a much simpler
example like evaluate an evaluation cell
yeah okay so let's try that here okay
and why the heck is this saying
selection move well this is bad let's
just fix that I think it works on
notebook selection okay so look um why
don't we start off here just saying
you
what is this was the definition yeah I
just saw that that's a bug that that was
generated that was submitted before we
had the definition of books stored for
it but uh the definition cell generated
that's my bug it didn't it didn't read
it and when I had read protected on it I
can fix that okay so you need to fix
this one but then why don't you put an
additional example with you know
evaluation cell and something else as
well yeah I can take care of it okay
you
for my said to maximize readability
okay
what on earth does that mean it's mainly
just adding line breaks in and
whitespace is this really the best
example of that
you
magnificent harlech end up being green
oh it did some okay whereas the non
readable form
put form I'll go
nice but now why is it in the font of of
input form rather than
I specifically wanted it to have like
the syntax highlighting and string
characters shown
okay Brian is asking how about author
specific namespaces yes one could do
that that the whole point here is to try
and have I mean okay that that's
and somewhat akin to contexts other than
global not necessarily a bad thing yeah
I accept that people don't like using
them I mean that's the except yes what's
that I agree with you there there is
that except right wrong with them it's
just people don't like them right yeah I
mean the question so this question about
how the publisher enters in the name and
so on and which which version you know
if two people have a particular name I
mean we're trying to make it so it's as
simple as possible for people to use
this stuff and yeah I mean you know look
I can imagine a time when one would have
something where there's a publisher name
that appears on top of this why have we
not done that so far good question what
can we address that question for a
second um avoid the publisher name
doesn't appear in there yeah I mean why
do we not allow people you know we could
have something where instead of this it
is essentially like a context name the
name of the publisher and then they're
readable form or somebody else's
readable form now I'm trying to remember
why we have chosen not to do that so far
I think if it's coming from the central
repository we want to keep it this way
but maybe for cloud deployed resources
we can investigate something like that
well
walk me through what the
let me think about this for a second I
mean the basic point is that we believe
that the sort of space of things that
can be done is broad enough yeah I mean
this is again the challenge that people
um I mean I have to say it's not
obviously silly to have something where
there is a branded name of you know
who's readable form is this so to speak
why did we stop doing that we put some
things and people didn't like typing
resource functions are now be : you know
our x9 degree or whatever it was I see
well and so we had a mechanism for this
and it's coming from the you know the
repository proper I think we just want
to keep the simple name and users and
other developers can have namespaces
provided through you know Claude
makélélé right like you say it's a
canonical research function called
readable form that is you know vetted
and good and we've published it really
useful if you want to have you know
secondary name spaces that are your
second-class citizens that is also this
whole that the whole point is that
there's a hierarchy here you know to get
something that reaches the standards of
our built-in functions as lots and lots
of work and many of these things you
know just it isn't gonna happen or
they're too specialized you know the
chaos game thing is not going to make it
to be a built-in function because it's
too specialized to think it would end up
being some part of some much more
general you know random iteration
something or other thing um so anyway
let's continue these are but I you know
it's great to get these comments okay
add sugar that's a really pretty
standard thing I know why that isn't a
built-in function but it isn't
okay replace all outside what on earth
is this lab sorry wrong color we need to
fix that
yeah why aren't we doing a regeneration
of everything by the way now that we
have we did that one I think was right
as we had that update and I think we
just need to while we were going through
and probably missed it as a rule and an
attempt to transform the entire
expression while ignoring
sub-expressions contain and accept
okay exotic but reasonable okay
what is this that's amusing why is it
only reflecting points why isn't it
reflecting everything
because it's only in the function
repository okay fair enough okay
cute okay could we please put a
separator line in here I let me not pull
it out and do that but that should have
a separator line that makes sense yep
and this should also have details that
say it can be 2d and 3d
I would assume although it's pretty
obvious from the examples but you know
we like to put in things like that again
very few you know I want to I want to be
you know for example here we should be
able to have some machine learning ish
thing that will determine that there
should have been a separator line here
very least it's deeply suspicious if
there's more than let's say two or three
input outputs without a separator line I
have thought about that a bit and I
think I could come up with a reasonable
heuristic just really look for variable
names or previous symbols or percent
signs and things like that it's fine if
there aren't some of those and it's it
yeah yeah good point good point if it
isn't percenter fiying and it's more
than two lines it's probably wrong yeah
exactly but I mean if it doesn't strung
back so to speak you know I can imagine
cases where you say this is how this
works this is how this works but you're
not going to do that for more than two
maybe three lines and if it goes further
without connection it's a sign that
there should have been a separator so
that's a good heuristic to add at least
you can suggest it in the you know
pre-flight yes like well yes but you can
also run it to suggest in the pre-flight
okay image two data URI what the heck is
this basically like an HTML blob for an
image oh I see so you get in my image
images
okay this should have a separator line
again these are two completely different
examples and it'd be really good to see
these actually work right
I mean if we've if we've got whatever
doggone Beach thing this is why can we
not see this as in an HTML export
am I making sense how would i this is
what I insert I think useful where is it
useful
I could think of an example like just
inserting that into some basic HTML
cloud to playing it as HTML and then
just show a screenshot of it would
probably make sense right so we've now
got web image so we can just use web
image oh yeah that's more enduring why
compress isn't like a wolf how is this
an improvement I'm just using compress
because it's got all the tagging
information at the beginning this the
browser knows how to display that oh
okay I'm gonna see the tags and stuff
looks good
oh boy this is an old function
I recognize this guy downtime
it's been renamed
looks good
why isn't this how I see ya
okay reasonable enough or cosecant
degree I think it will be okay all right
let's do another one
there's a lot of mathy things here
partition from Frobenius symbol
you
yeah a couple of our most habit internal
submitters are people okay but I don't
understand why this is why is he doing
it this way why didn't you just say this
thing all of that element again that's
another thing to try to detect Rick yeah
I mean I can't see no reason I don't
know all variable names refer to yeah
it's just crazy that that's definitely
something I've thought about but there's
other lower hanging fruit
I think first okay wait what was the
issue if you scroll up there what was
the complaint about his f1 I'm saying
that there's no reason to define the f1
and then do this and never to refer to
the f1 again I think the reason is so
that you can visually see that this is a
matrix with two decreasing etc etc it's
right now I mean you could put it right
now then we have two separate lines of
comment that that don't really go well
he's introducing well what what the
operand is it's not my favorite way of
doing it but understand is it heinous no
it's not heinous but it's not preferred
okay I'm only claiming in this instance
that there seems to be reasonable okay
it's not completely weird funny that
this
view bytes listen I'll call bytes view
but but I mean it could more like a
bytes plot or something
cool this one this one this it might not
be professional hey guys I think the
lists that i used to provide those
random functions i think you're looking
on that's not well why is it looks just
like a reasonable thing to me there are
some things i wanted to fix on it okay i
see that's pretty weird
so printable ASCII it's just gonna
appear print well I mean the visual
graphic design of this could be more
wonderful yeah there are there things
over gun and I think that's why we
didn't fully push it like the smallest
parts and the integer partitions of that
positive integer
it is actually a function according to
Wikipedia and mathworld I believe that
obscure though no that's fine that's
what the functional buzzer tree is for
notebook history dialog why is that the
crazy dialog why isn't it the data from
it yeah but there isn't to see also how
isn't there a seal so can we get that to
happen
yep okay so that brought that up that
was dandy so now if I say notebook
history data that correction cool
asaurus I mean those are horrifying
absolute times and things but that's the
way it provides it I mean I don't know
we want to pre-process it here
you could have an option date for
meckel's to date object or something
okay ordinal number string da for I'm
very bad at pronouncing those but okay
that's obviously useful
you
you
that's a little bit in felicitous oh I
see it's just going to give that's not
very exciting is it okay perfectly
harmless
okay
is there a companion to orbital or
ordinal number string that gives you the
pronounceable version well I assume that
you know the fact is ordinal numbers
string that would be a problem
by the way Rick it should never do this
I mean why aren't you setting the
formatting always to come back as the
unev a lighted blob I mean I can do that
it's just it's a little tricky you know
it though was worried about accidentally
stomping over existing formatting
definitions by doing that automatically
wasn't there a generic way to do the
formatting or are all these different
symbols they're all in different tongue
they're all in different contexts right
right and it's it's not necessarily
known that I mean I guess it would make
sense to do it for the symbol that
represents the like the exported
function yes but other like dependent
symbols probably not because those Kajal
returners oh yeah well they could
potentially be returned but I think
that's up to the person I think you
should do it by default for this one
look can we not detect which ones are
returnable eventually we should be able
to detect which ones are returnable I
don't think that would be possible in
the general case but one thing I could
do is if there are no format values
defined for the symbol add that roll in
to format it otherwise itself yeah so if
somebody is to find their own formatting
for it I would have it just don't touch
it but if there's not no that's what I
would do okay
we'll give a shout-out to anyone
watching of the resource function format
as resource function that does that they
can specify it explicitly I noticed this
shingled has no contributor on it yeah
if you delete the contributor by field
well you treat it as anonymous if you
want to give us good stuff and you don't
what anyone to know it was you that's
okay
apparently there's another livestream
starting on Association and data set
from who is doing that so I'm curious
one of our core developers I think not
sure who um so we'll we'll wrap this up
fairly soon here um 5-10 minutes um it
seems okay
oh gosh what is all this no that's awful
come on guys look we got to stop people
doing this this is really stupid this is
like writing Fortran code or something
making sense
well the author's here yeah as the
author is thinking about it okay
oh it's good to have them so t8 was
asking is there a way to remove your
contributor by credit yeah there is you
just delete that cell I believe and your
underlying publisher ID is not displayed
if you retrieve the source notebook from
the repository you can submit as the
original publisher between is an updated
review and so whatever you know but
you're answering a different question
the question was if you want to be an
anonymous contributor can you do that
and the answer is yes right even from
the get-go right right if you have one
that's published already and you want to
remove it yeah I guess I answered yes
underwear you mentioned not showing a
publisher ID but that is something I
think we'll want to add to these pages
in the future well that's a good
question for people I'd be interested to
know if there is a if people want to be
able to contribute anonymously I mean I
don't think we can particularly we want
to make sure we know what who's doing
what for various reasons yeah we we have
to know that because otherwise otherwise
there are all kinds of things like
somebody's got to actually put the
things you know assign the thing to have
a correct license and stuff like this
yes there has to be some knowledge of
who is doing something I don't know how
that works and other platforms where
people just say oh I'm putting this I
mean that that's a very weird thing if
that's just on github for example if
somebody says this is operating with
this license and I'm just called you
know Q or something
how well are our publisher ID system can
support like a display name that doesn't
know I understand
way about you I guess I'm asking a
question I don't know the answer to
which is how do you know that Q is able
to I mean Q is saying they don't you
don't know who it is but they're
assuring you that they're allowed to do
what they're doing it's a little weird
um okay listen this doesn't cut it in my
view we can get rid of the M and I like
having it reproducible with seed random
that's fine but I mean just put that I
don't sell my units a Maitre you could
you should add one example before this
that's this matrix pencil style the two
by two maybe well why don't I mean it
it's just look I could do it with real
numbers sure what happens if I just do
this you ever get something ugly I bet
why didn't that work I have no idea
oh because wait a minute or it has to be
no it is square I don't know why list of
matrices matrices oh right sorry
yeah this was something a constant
requested I completely forgot what it
does that's why I'm an in our different
okay I don't know what this result is
but in this case you've probably got a
generalized eigen system okay I mean you
could try eigen system or of those two
matrices and see in fact under under
properties and relations I have an
example like that I see
see ok i remember these pictures alright
well but they're no huge objections here
i mean the fact and the fact that
there's an M there even those M's up
here is a bit confusing but that's a
detail well I'm just gonna get rid of
you know just hardwired the Amman on in
there and yeah I don't know some way
this is saying funked I see this is
another I see well I don't know might
isn't just saying X cubed in both places
what is this why does it say stationary
and rising in lowercase I know I
understand yes but I mean why is well I
see I mean those are like common names
for those things yeah that was the
design respect when we discussed it on
it from the Alpha side that's similar to
what you'd get from alpha what happened
to this work in 12 zero right I think so
not sure why it's not evaluating
something is wrong here some of these
alpha scanner things oh yeah
you need a packet update is why as well
but that has to go out before the
function repository goes out because
otherwise people are gonna get the wrong
answer here to read this one is tough my
on it's been published the back one's
been published so why it was so so if I
do what do I have to tackle an update
alpha scanner functions and why wouldn't
I get it by default it's in the layout
but there were that auto update wise no
update it is in versions 12 1 plus but
in 12 oh I didn't get on what that's not
that's not good enough I mean listen
this I understand yeah right so whatever
whatever you know whatever scheme you
have has to cause this to just work we
have to pull it from the function
response rate which is not good things I
know this is needed for other stuff also
market as requiring 12.1 without calling
it and then if 12 people one of
reference it it's probably the way to go
well I I know why don't we get it to
actually work yeah I believe I know it
what's happening here okay so why did
was that it's not caught in testing
aren't we running all the examples here
as regression tests we are why wasn't
this court the pack what literally just
got pushed today there were some other
updates and okay so it was previously
failing and it will get it will stop
failing soon as that yes and I believe
it'll work yes yes all that Mister okay
and and the regression tests who's who
are those tests going to we need to
specify I'm not speaking of the
regression test having anything to do
with the Wolfen function repository
these are Pacolet tests in this
particular case there's Pacolet tests
that cue a regular QA is is in charge
okay I'm talking about the function
repository I mean this has just happens
to be that it's a core Pacolet but
there's no reason for that I mean I'm
asking about the desktop you idiot
there's a kernel of testing team Wow
look at that
Wow cool how does it even
it's giving I see multiple axes plot but
that's that's assuming two curves and
it's plotting them Wow people have been
asking this for this for millions of
years that's really cool nice and
there's a good example of one where it's
not really that general but it's still
um you know but it's already useful
it'll get used it'll definitely get used
this is from an old but what's that why
is that weird white thing I said that
background color should be blue I mean
it's rasterize there on the lighter
color that's wrong yeah I'll take a look
at that um okay I thought we should
times
go to it sander had a good question
okay cipher you know ultimately with
something like Caesar cipher we should
have a way to slot that in to encrypt
and decrypt and that's one of the
challenges like like we've built
specific repositories for dealing with
things like net model but um you know
for encrypt in principle there should be
a way to slot in an additional method
I'm it's a tricky one in this case I
would tend to think see it depends well
this is part of a family of functions
where there are cases I mean in this
particular case it's rather trivial
because it's just you know rotating by
that amount but you know for instance I
don't know if you hadn't an enigma
cipher I don't think well I don't even
know but I it's not something that um
yeah I mean I feel like if there if it
was part of a family of functions where
some of them had non-trivial deciphering
and other ones had trivial deciphering
there will be more argument to have a
decipher variant as well as the in
cipher in variant but if it's just a
one-off thing I agree in this case it's
kind of silly to have a separate
deciphering function but it's it's
tricky I mean these things are always
unfortunately these design things you
know as you expand the scope of what
you're dealing with the design becomes
sort of evermore complicated and they're
evermore constraints so I think it's a
okay so vineya cipher also has this
property right that it is just Stephen I
think it'd be productive to restate the
question which is basically when to add
more functionality into a single
function versus but
multiple yes yes I mean I'll see force a
Caesar cipher can be its own decipher
but most ciphers can't exactly and so is
it weird for this why do I not have a
yeah this this myself okay pointed to
the vinyasa um as well just as a matter
of them oh come now
oh I think there might be another a in
there oh yeah so spelling but it should
be able to find it even not good okay so
if I go back here and I press Santa's
name that doesn't work yet I would
really love to see all the all the
things he's contributed that would have
to be tied to the publish right he well
know it'll be a textual search couldn't
in search for sander that could work it
works I mean unless somebody has a
function about a belt sander right okay
so why are we not finding this that was
a bug in the oh I see because the
separated wood has a husband there the
text search index might be choking on
the diacritic that's bad yeah we can
clear that up okay so in this case how
does by the way that's not the most
beautiful thing here because of I mean
wouldn't it be nicer when we give an
external link I guess I guess we're just
giving URLs that's probably reasonable
um
you can use I but I don't see any
problem with anybody doing that right I
have got to go to my outside meeting and
I'm encouraging people to go see under
SlashGear who's talking about
Association and data set but I don't you
know with respect to this fit I thought
they were called Phineas ciphers but
maybe they're not maybe I never read the
word properly
those cases there are these there are
these words that I realized that I
learnt as a kid and I never read every
letter in them and I've said them wrong
vote like decades this might be an
example of that does anybody know how to
pronounce this okay
well at least nobody on the live call um
knows I'm wrong okay but so in this case
is the decipherment I don't even know
what happens here is this decipherment
non-trivial
what firm is near which i think is
Visionnaire okay the deciphering is
non-trivial yeah so there has to be a
separate vineya decipher function it's
not true
I think so thank you sense to have a
Caesar decipher just because it would be
easy for people to find even if it is
just a trivial to implement well I mean
I'm getting convinced by seeing this
other case that you know if there's a
family of these things we're gonna have
to have that so I think my conclusion is
that the the Caesar d4 cipher does make
sense because this one needs a
non-trivial decipher and other ones like
it will need not reveal these ciphers um
yeah I I should take back what I said
I'm not sure if it's non-trivial it's
non-trivial to decrypt if you understand
yeah analysis it's non-trivial but
that's a different thing
yeah but to do just G I think that would
be a nice function to have as a caesar
crypt analysis I I think I've done that
in a bunch of things I've done with like
kids and so on that's one of the
examples I've used a few times um okay
well we should wrap it up here I think
you know my main conclusion from this
well what is as we say we need to wrap
it up you know this is that this is a
process because one can't go too far or
you know once doing system functions
again but and I don't know how many we
got through we got through maybe about
40 here and this took an hour
ish so we were doing about one every
minute minute and a half um
on average and you know 40 we have so
that means it's would take to go through
even what we have right now would take
10 hours at this level um you know I
think you know an interesting question
is if we have something out there and
it's kind of a battle at bad design how
do we change that design and the answer
is it's a little tricky because we're
going to have to you know that name will
have already been claimed and we're
going to end up having to do you know
something with versioning it's gonna be
a little tricky that that's why
versioning is gonna be pretty high on
our priority list um well I understand
that but um oh boy Ethan is saying lots
of resource functions that use dynamics
don't work in the cloud that's
horrifying
um okay
just you know I'm a little concerned
here as well as we're looking at this
and actually you know we should have
done one of these reviews before I'm a
little freaking out here because the I
am concerned about things where the
design is just wrong but where it's a
name that is the obvious name yet the
design is wrong what should we be doing
in that case because you know for system
functions we are we don't make that
mistake terribly often because we've had
lots and lots of experience of designing
these things and you know we kind of
know how to review them but in this case
we're not exercising anything like that
level of scrutiny and so we're going to
make mistakes what do we do if the
function I mean that's why I think it's
very important to have defensive naming
for these things well if we if we have a
good versioning system then even if
someone is reliant on for example select
first by using the existing argument
order we could change it with a
different version but they can still get
that old version know something you can
use my free source function of quotes
blah blah blah right how do they get the
old I mean if that's if that code
contains resource function of quotes
select first by what what are we gonna
get well we'd have to provide a way for
that to indicate the version no I know
but people are either look people are
not gonna do that they're gonna put in
you know select first by and then
they're going to say you know I want
that to be and that's why we had had the
idea which I thought we'd implemented
that these blobs wherever there is an
example of one of those a blob like this
would contain its versioning information
so if you were to use that blob in your
code then it would burn in the correct
version we can look into that I think
that so you run into issues when you
know if it's if you've cashed a version
locally and it's relying on the cash
functionality then it won't work at the
same if I you know send you a definition
and you know no downloading the new
version so no I'm saying I'm saying if
you use the blob like that then you get
a frozen version whatever the version
was at the time that blob was created
anybody who sees that blob gets the
version that I words that's a version
version so to speak as opposed yeah next
version which would not be a version
version that makes it yeah we can we can
kick this idea around and see what kind
of sounded like that we can do so so
what we could do
does resource function have a second
argument it's for properties of the
resource function but I'm thinking a
probably make sense to have an option to
specify the version at the top level of
resource function well really what would
we want to do is we want to have some
form where you can say resource function
of like either a version or a publisher
name or something like that so that you
can do this so if you do need to do it
textually you have a reasonably simple
form and that becomes one of these blobs
that has the version burn 10 right yeah
we don't wait simple text-based way of
doing that we'll be putting together a
design for you to look at hopefully soon
ok well I think yeah sander is making
comments along the same lines I think
the main point is that the blob that
should be versioned
okay the text should not be version but
the blob is versioned that makes sense
to people and that means that the blob
that code then involves the blob we'll
never stop working because it will
always use the version that it
originally of that original thing and if
you want the most recent version you go
back to the textual form yep we can we
can incorporate them okay okay although
although that probably means that we'll
need a right-click menu item here that
says make textual or something or make
something like that all right hey listen
really appreciate well the local folk
and and the folks on the live stream um
I I kind of feel like we should do
another one of these soon before we
actually release this thing
to make sure we're not making any
horrible mistakes um okay
much appreciated see you soon backed by
expert